All right.
Hello, welcome. It's
March 22nd, 2026.
This is Daniel Friedman in for Ant
Stream 18.1.
This stream is going to use the doxology
template repo
maybe to be moved to an institute repo
in the future
and explore this self-generating
package/paper
as always in active debugging mode.
We will discuss topics like
reproducibility and scientific workflow
for papers with different amounts of
formalism and prose.
Look through the overall structure of
the repo, the top-level infrastructure,
methods, orchestration, documents, and
the project scale.
The
application of thin orchestrator
and separation of consideration for
different parts of the code base in the
projects.
Look at running multiple projects with
the top-level run commands
and see what people put in the chat for
ideas or questions.
To begin, you can probably just check
the most recent version of the repo and
methods are hopefully properly
documented at that time.
Um
okay.
Where we're going is
rendering
a PDF that looks like this
with
color of your choice, linking to
different sections of the paper
configurable type setting
automatic numbering hypertext,
code reference
inserting images
However
also running that scientific code to get
that
uh output.
Uh lot lots of ways to enter into this.
We'll start with the overall structure
of the repo, then look at the project
scale.
And
look at the in in in looking at the
project, hopefully somebody will have
suggested something in the chat for just
some
project and we will see how far
uh one-shotting
in cursor and/or anti-gravity
just a suggestion for a project gets. So
delete some of these.
Okay. Top level of the repo.
Docs is documentation for the repo
itself.
Infrastructure
has the modules of code
methods definitions for each of these
submodules of code. This is kind of like
the toolkit
for
the
factory of
research replication that's about to be
orchestrated.
And there's a few general folder
strategies and um
everything being presented here is just
one way to do it. I eagerly look towards
other, simpler, different, better
methods. So just sharing where my
explorations have gotten me and learning
from different patterns
and looking forward to people
forking and and coming up with other
approaches.
Agents and a read me at every folder
level
and scale
files
at the submodule or finer scale
folder levels.
Maybe eventually these two will be
unneeded
because you could just iterate across a
whole repo and say put a scale file in
or scale to generate scales
but uh it it helps with some of the
coherence of the different methods.
The infrastructure methods are tested
with the top-level test suite.
The infra tests is the same modules as
the infrastructure unit tests
and the integration are combining across
different modules.
Scripts in general are going to be thin
orchestrators, so ideally not defining
any
major or any methods in these scripts
themselves, just calling upon
methods in this case defined in the
infrastructure layer.
And
when you run this
there's two entry points
from the top level.
Run and secure run.
And they're both going to do basically
the same thing. Secure run is going to
additionally apply the steganography
module, but we'll just work mainly with
run
for now unless maybe we'll try later.
From the top level
./
run.sh
and the text menu will come up.
And it will
uh give options
based upon scanning for what projects
are in the projects folder. So also I
have some untracked folders
that are their own private repos that
won't be used today probably for
projects archive and projects in
progress.
Projects just itself is going to be kind
of like the the projects that are on the
burner. So you could have one or more.
They're kind of like separately
stand-alone projects.
And there's code project, which is just
a simple placeholder
project with example documented of the
project structure.
And then in this case the recently
published paper
for this repo
as a manuscript
to understand how the package sort of
rendered this and ran the analysis and
rendered the manuscript.
Um
and the output is just a secondary
copying when you run ./ run.
There options to set up
the environment
and do each step by itself from scripts
or run full pipeline.
Usually I don't run plus infra tests
because that's a very large test suite,
but it's it's good to have 100% working
or if anything is not working on your
system
confirming that the test suite is all
updated is a good way to debug um or
rebug there.
Plus or minus LLM here means that
there's uh post-publication
so to speak
review of different personad LLM
using local LLM calls.
And then the fastest option, which is
just running the projects themselves
end to end is the all project fast,
which is just without the infra test,
without the LLM
analysis. So
I'll pick option D.
First clear the output folder.
So it's going to iterate over each of
the projects in the project folder.
Each of them have these following
folders.
SRC for the code
tests for the testing of the SRC code
scripts to orchestrate the SRC code.
Output
for where everything is going to get
saved and rendered into.
Manuscript
modular markdown files and configuration
and docs within the project, which is
technical documentation for the project.
So the goal is that each of these
projects is completely stand-alone
and the the repo template level dot dot
slash run
the dot
run dot sh
will just orchestrate the scripts
which have validated stand-alone
functionality
composing the source code methods.
And the top-level run.sh will
run the test suite
the data analysis and any any other uh
needed methods for the project.
Then look to the manuscripts markdowns
and the type setting configuration
and then render it in
to the final
output
which uh
has some degrees of freedom for type
setting.
Most
probably many of many of the basic ones.
Maybe there's other type setting
approaches, but
um margins, different colors, font size
uh inserting hard-coded and generated
images
and a few other interesting aspects.
Um,
like
injecting the variables in
uh, having equations and injecting
variables
directly into the manuscript.
Um,
so when you re-render the manuscript, it
has updated
values.
Here's the previous
uh, run.sh running.
Going iterating through and here the
different output types within each
project.
There are
the citation information,
the raw data
from the analysis of the paper,
any
additional documentation,
the images,
the figures of the paper,
the optional LLM review analysis,
the run log of the rendering,
which could have any warnings,
uh, re-outputting the manuscript
markdowns,
the PDF,
and all of the LaTeX debugging and other
formats.
Uh, reports,
any validation reports or additional
technical material
that
uh, are included,
any simulation data,
then the uh,
paper
in slides,
depending on the sec- you you could make
section length very small
to make more of a slide presentation.
But, going to a uh, slide
uh, LaTeX
and the web
HTML
format of the paper.
Okay.
So, that was the completion of
top-level running
./run.sh.
Iterates over the projects in the
project folder
using the orchestration from the repo
layer of the scripts orchestrating the
infrastructure methods
>> [snorts]
>> tested here.
First, runs the outer loop
to confirm the functionality of the
template repo.
Then, these code project and template
projects
are like
control positive
um,
or and templates for starting a new
project. So, anyone can suggest in the
live chat or I'll think of something
random in a minute for some other
project
and we'll explore creating a few
parallel projects
um, and kind of one-to-few shotting
bootstrapping off the format of the
control positives that are documented
and using that to explore different uh,
pros
and qualitative and quantitative
research seeds.
All right, we'll just start, but
I'll wait one more minute for anyone to
write anything, but I'll I'll start with
write a prompt now
for starting with
as
positive control
projects
convey that
format and then write the prompt
to one-shot make a new
project along those lines
appending only then
the suggestion someone has
or idea of project.
All right, meanwhile, let's see if the
uh, steganographic
methods are working right now.
./secure run.
Pick option D again.
Delete output folder.
Thank you, Joelner.
Antigravity
at least currently has a very high
level
of using the
Claude Sonnet Opus 4.6 and the Gemini
3.1.
So, I'm using both Cursor and
Antigravity
just overlapping.
Keep- keeping both within a sort of
uh,
utility balanced
cost and kind of trading off month to
month as different offers and things
happen.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'll start a chat.
Control L add this prompt.
In
make a new project
with
main subsection documents and
all modular methods
and tested properly, really.
A project
if
and use
a
a project exploring
concordances of
what?
Exploring
We'll set up a few of these. I'm just
waiting if anyone writes anything in the
chat.
Start with
making
a
holistic report of an area.
And rendering it
into
updated handbook.
A project exploring
using the methods to
render
a
16-page
newspaper
traditional style and layout.
Project exploring
different
different density of
gases and fluids
and density of insect
bodies
in speculative analysis.
A project exploring
how unlikely
certain
kinds of
special
numbers
irrational
transcendental
are to be close to certain
integer ratios
statistically.
Okay.
So, four parallel projects starting up
in in cursor there.
Um
Right. We'll start one more
in this
folder
using example of
make a whole new project
just for
Hm.
Virtual environment
setup
and
modular
interactive
active inference
browser-based games with standalone
math package
use at perplexity
everything.
Anti-gravity only has one
chat ongoing on the right.
But cursor has
multiple.
I don't and I I
I I've explored and
uh
used some of the
terminal agents, but we'll probably just
keep it on
the chat agents here.
Just just to have a better better sense
of what's going on.
Okay.
So, the we'll just
play around here for a few minutes.
Uh see if we can keep each of these
projects get them get them to a few uh
prompts down the road.
Run
from the top
all the renderings.
If they each take a 10 10 or 60 seconds,
we should get through a few iterations
and just sort of work all the errors and
warnings out and just show how we can
rapidly develop these projects in
parallel.
So, each of them let's look into the
newspaper.
So, projects traditional newspaper.
We have the inheritance of the top-level
structure, the general folder hygiene of
the readme and agents.
The SRC methods
which can be Python
in a flat folder
or there can be sub modules within SRC.
The scripts
that orchestrate the SRC methods, the
tests that test them.
And
here manuscript sections. We'll just
it's
um and and then here here's the agents'
progression on that project. So,
sequentially making those
templated
uh files and folders
we'll just
run run again
and see see if it is it it it may not be
done, but in the agentic loop
it can it will know
that
it should try to run
the end-to-end setup test
render validate.
Um
possibly with these
Yeah,
using from the infrastructure model uh
repo level code
using the validation
methods
as a terminal command to call
to
uh give a pass
test
that the markdown are compliant
with what is expected to
render properly.
So, being able to call the the these
dozens to hundreds of tools
and write very modular files given a
work plan
with minimal intervention
huge game changer. And those can be
dispatched for
Hermes, OpenClaw
Codex, etc.
So, here is the agent calling
the
scripts from [snorts] the top level of
the repo
which are the thin orchestrators of
infrastructure methods.
Running the scripts
with just the with the
dash dash project
flag
the command line option
for traditional newspaper.
So, that's going to run the stages that
run.sh is going to run
for them sequentially
headlessly
here running agentically
for um
and able to then have the logging.
So, here it's
11/16
completed processing.
Um we'll go to
output folder.
Check some of this.
Just while it's
look at the other ones.
This is a this is a little bit like uh
play playing a few epistemic horses at
once.
Probably not the
uh most
deep work
ask way
to work, but a but a fun mode
nonetheless.
When when
uh
working with template, usually I keep
just the one project that I'm actually
working on
plus
one or two of the control positive
>> [snorts]
>> short projects
just so that uh I can from the top level
run
run my project of interest, have a
configurability
setup uh with subsetting to to use like
1% of the data um
like if it were a genetics or genomics
analysis using 1% of the samples or 1%
of the loci.
And so, it runs fast
confirming that the output numbers, the
sample size, the statistics get injected
into the manuscript
based upon the plain text output from
the validated analysis.
Uh
build out the methods and tests on the
small subset of the data
or if it's a if it's a a low data paper,
just the whole data set
each time even if it takes a few
minutes.
And
running it looking at the final PDF
rendering
seeing asking writing manually how it
could be different, going into the
manuscript files, manually editing them.
Um
keeping it functional end-to-end.
So,
like we'll see from these that we're
spinning up now
even the very first
uh
generative AI produced draft
can still lead to a
totally functional PDF
rendering.
Like
okay, here's the newspaper.
Huh, three panels.
So,
No.
It's a start. It still is rendering.
Um
but
the
it it
keeps the
final form in mind.
What an an interesting topic to return
to is I think what forms are beyond and
outside of of that rendering.
Like as we explore this and other
modular document production methods
reading and writing
for science and meta-science
the rendering
separating it from the underlying
methods
becomes kind of a core theme.
Okay, here's the special numbers
paper.
We'll check um if these methods were
properly injected.
And and what it all means, but you know,
first shot
some LaTeX rendering
those those can be just say oh, in this
section it looks like that.
Or
uh anti-gravity has a Chrome browser
plugin. So,
it can it can look at the HTML and the
PDF
in a closed loop and go through several
rounds of visual review.
So, here we'll look at that.
Special numbers
results.
So, these look hardcoded. So, it hasn't
yet injected.
But then prompting and documenting and
enforcing
that everything is configurable and
modular and no values are hardcoded, no
section names are hardcoded
no configuration parameters are
hardcoded.
A future step is even having the
writing component that generated
downstream of the results for certain
parts. So, for example, introduction
section could be
hardcoded
with with citations.
Um
I maybe even pre-registered.
Then the
methods and the results
can be
strongly enforced to be injectable
with the configuration of the actual
sample size run and the actual
statistics of that run.
And the figures generated from that run.
Um
and then in the discussion
like
right now
the natural language part is static.
We'll say
on this many samples this percentage
change happened.
Um but to kind of interpret it
that could also be generated downstream
from changing numbers. Like imagine if
it was you know, the initial evidence or
the subset was a positive relationship,
but it ended up being negative. That
changes how the interpretation in the
discussion
would bear on what else had been
discovered.
Um okay.
Here we go.
So, the projects are starting to finish
up their first round.
Okay.
Cut. And then I'm going to paste this
into each of them.
Comprehensively improve and add methods
testing, documentation
manuscript sections and files to this
project
you are working on.
And that's that's kind of a message that
you can
poke it with
essentially after a completion or or
during.
Right.
This one is working on the
active inference application.
So, this one will have a uh
it
you can have
a
stub
uh
source code
that's just a pass-through
to confirm that there's not intended to
be anything there.
And
just have manuscript manually written
sections.
So, that would be like using
this uh template repo as a
manually written type
processing
suite.
All the way on through
uh reproducible analysis or scalable
analysis of
different areas of research.
On through
kind of generative
research writing methods
and including different meta-science
features into the pipeline
like pulling literature
different API calls, different LLMs for
writing.
Um
different renderings of of final
artifacts, nano publications.
Okay.
So, we got
that one
newspaper
area handbook
special numbers.
Density. Huh.
Clear the output folder.
Run again.
So,
skipping the infra test layer.
Going to the first of the seven
projects.
Cleaning the output directories.
Creating that's step two of eight within
the project
within this active inference app.
Running the setup methods.
Step three.
Running the project level testing.
Logging the project level test.
Collecting project level errors.
Either allowing the project to proceed
or not proceed depending on an error
threshold in the test suite.
Here
continuing on
not having a strict threshold allowing a
failing test and continuing to the
analysis phase.
Um running that
those orchestration
scripts
which ostensibly in the testing phase
all the methods invoked have been
validated.
Getting errors.
Getting useful error messages.
Like here we can see oh, it's installing
the SciPy dependency because
the setup methods as orchestrated did
not include the proper setup of SciPy.
So, now it's figuring out how to do that
and it's
going through those tests
and fixing those failures and just going
one by one until the entire test suite
works.
And then just adding more methods,
adding more tests, fixing the tests.
Um
getting the errors from the orchestrated
methods. And then here popping up this
app.
Let's see if it does anything.
Okay.
Nope.
Moving.
uncertainty in an environment, different
beliefs.
Here now popping up in a different
browser.
This glowing window
is anti-gravity
taking control of the browser.
Getting the browser information from the
website.
Taking visual screenshots.
So, we'll just let that
work over there.
I'm going to
pull
active inference app
into projects in progress
and have anti-gravity improve it.
Completely improve this app and all
methods and orchestration,
validation, animation, documentation.
Because the agent can work on it. It
doesn't really care whether it's
parent project folder is
what what it's called. It's
as long as it's projects in progress.
Because the running the app kind of
interferes with the
um
run sh loop. So,
that that that would kind of you know
you could use this for general projects
um
orchestration.
However, the pipeline is intended to be
more like scientific publication, even
if it takes hours or days to run the
job.
So, we'll just run Now, we run run the
sh again.
Clear output.
Just delete that folder.
Now,
run the sh.
D
The first project it finds is the area
study.
So, it's going to render
the sections of the main script
plus orchestrate
whatever source code
and scripts are there.
So, we'll we'll we'll see what where AI
gets.
Here's rendering those sections step by
step.
Okay.
Newspaper coming along.
Compiling the PDF. There may be a faster
way.
So, if anyone has any ideas for for how
to make this
um faster.
Maybe
render the subsections with parallel
threads.
Okay, so the here's the warnings.
This can be
uh taken back in
to improve the formatting, but here's
what we get
from that first render.
Short
stops.
Starting point, though.
Then just moves on to the next
uh
paper.
Okay. Let's all I'm going to look at the
live chat.
Uh
and back to the initial stream agenda.
Go through any last points.
See if anyone has an idea for a project
or a question. Uh otherwise, then we'll
pretty much
finish it.
All right.
There are a few dependencies to have
installed related to the document
processing.
So,
if anybody sets it up on their ends,
um
give any feedback on how the initial
setup can go.
And also improving the LLM component,
which is currently using Ollama. I I
know there's other ways that we can use
the LLM.
Um and explore kind of
cross-project methods
like with embeddings and other methods.
Okay. Okay.
Type one if you're here for the
pipeline.
Two for the study.
Three for both.
Computational reproducibility is often a
workflow problem. Manuscript, code,
data, and build steps drift because
nothing in the tool chain enforces them
as one system.
Um at risk of
of uh the the Tower of Babel style
totalizing tool development
mode
with with each person's personal flavor
added into that general pattern.
Um
that kind of fragmentation, at least in
my own experience for projects and
having all these different
informal,
formal manuscript draft, different code
versioning, file names, some stuff on
Git, others not. Um it's like a lot of
context switching,
a lot of possibilities, and uh cognitive
load
to just increment in a lot of projects
that therefore don't end up having the
rigor, accessibility, applicability that
they might if they were to be in a sort
of more scaffolded, cultivated,
augmented intelligence niche.
So, the idea of this template repo,
which I guess we can look at the repo's
history, but it's been versioning over
the last few months
and uh continuing to revisit it just
every time a new or better model comes
out.
Checking the docs for coherence.
Using a to-do
top-level file to coordinate incremental
releases, so allowing increasingly
capable models and processes
to review
the patterns and documentation and
develop incremental improvement
and refactoring recommendations
and using other sorts of augmented
coding pointed on the template repo. So,
improving the general
um
strategy
while developing
exemplar
and published and
um
deliverable only published or
fully provided. So, kind of like the
difference between open  complete
source. If you just take this whole
folder as like a briefcase, it's going
to have all the methods for
reproducibility, all the generated data
as used for that rendering of the PDF.
So that's like the complete package.
Um or you could deliver just like the
output file.
And keep the keep some or all parts of
the project reproducibility on on your
side
private.
Um like drop in have a a project
template that you know works for a given
type of analysis like a GWAS.
Then copy it, modify the config, run it,
provide the client or whatever with the
output results or PDF render.
Based upon the upstream version of the
project template.
No mock tests. This is uh
sort of a uh issue that I'm sure people
who have explored
using LLMs for coding have hit up
against with the possibility of
disceptive
or innocently or silently misinformative
methods
and validations that really aren't and
hard-coded
plain text
um fabrication
that leads to
subsequent confirmatory analyses
even despite massive structural
otherwise obvious like
oh wait, you wanted me to analyze the
data now?
So really enforcing
with complete holistic scope
the real validated, documented, tested,
orchestrated, etc. All those different
kinds of
uh imperative
commands
uh and design principles
so that at the infrastructure level and
at the project layer
there's just like a a
pervasive
actuality to the analysis
and discussion uh as a reminder to keep
things on the rails.
Rendering to multiple targets
including a HTML website.
So
optimizing for a PDF might have a
difference. Uh
some different design strategies than
for HTML, but you can
kind of
basically make something that looks good
enough in both.
And the infrastructure
module steganography
has basic methods for with the secure
run
to wrap
and just apply at the very end these
steganographic metadata modifying
um
text
overlay, QR, barcode information in the
footer and the header and things like
that.
Okay.
All right, here here's Okay, now
so
that that red is the agents in
anti-gravity.
So here
all these JavaScript
now
doing
action on the browser.
Okay.
Special numbers chugging away.
Okay, close that one.
I'll just do a few more minutes of of uh
random stuff, but if anyone has a
comment or question, go for it.
All right, that one's done.
That one's done.
All right.
So we
still have the dot run running there.
Density project.
This note connects ideal gas reference
liquid densities to a reproducible or
openly specified composite mixture model
for arthropod scale effective density.
That's
writing very sparsely.
Hm.
Very interesting.
Special number.
Okay.
Newspaper.
All right, now we're talking.
Very nice.
Now
for the project
review and add as many
manuscript files and sections
paragraphs
use browser and all tools and
intelligence to keep
relevant and concise though
word count
realistically needs to double
or more.
Check all figures made properly
and captions
auto numbers
very informative
analyses.
The project is
paste.
>> [snorts]
>> Just
pasting it in.
Other orchestration methods obviously
you can
see how you could do this some parts of
this
with conditional statements and
iterating over folders.
Um or using different database
uh
metadata or file content-based
data.
Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> Something's happening, right? But
these values are not updating.
So that's
coming back to the idea of having the
uh
the foundational methods very verified
because then it's like huh
how confident should we be about the
variational free energy when it seems
like it's not changing?
So should we be confident in the
simulation, but
um
it it oh oh oh oh, you wanted Oh, you
wanted that to be calculated?
So
in building in those kinds of validation
expectations
um and stringency
allows these larger
multi-level packages
to get built out in a more
stigmergic
aligned niche.
Um
with with some reuse patterns
which in your own setting and hands may
be somewhat different uh design, but
just so some of these some of these
principles may be of use.
>> [snorts]
>> All right, I'll bring in a question.
Okay.
>> Okay.
I am zero in binary.
Not particularly for active inference,
but do you think about souls? While
active inference is for the mind, there
is nothing that touches the soul.
Yeah, great great question. Interesting
also to see that kind of soul.md
approach.
And
different
different proposed and resonance
or uh alien
cognitive partitions, thinking about
perception, action,
vision,
uh soul, memory, anticipation.
It It with all of this agent design and
kind of like word play,
uh and shape play.
Some of these uh
external engineered forms
and their resulting functions,
uh I feel
do come into that discussion that you
point towards.
Ensure all the
visualizations and animations are
validated and real, all updating. Use
the browser
tools extensively to check this.
Okay.
Newspaper.
Writing more.
Special numbers.
Density paper.
Writing more.
Cursor also with something like a
browser
uh within its
IDE.
But here's that
anti-gravity grabbing the real Chrome.
Headless uh terminal agents, cloud code,
uh codex, droid, etc. style, Hermes.
Um they have access to play right.
All these browser
methods as well.
So, sometimes it's kind of a frustrating
indirect way to get at
information
through this rendered or emulated
browser interface.
Other times for working with existing
and making new websites and web objects,
it's super effective.
So, here's the chain of of actions of
clicking on that one.
Maybe a sign-in issue.
Pick right back up.
Just
you were disrupted.
Continue now.
Bye.
Okay.
Tripled the pros in
bio scales.
And ideally, um
you There might be a brief moment during
a a live editing where a uh
where a top level
uh dot slash run option D
where this catches a paper in an
unrenderable form.
But if you look at the kinds of edits
that are made,
they are always end-to-end within a
compliant markdown
file.
So, at least for modifying the
manuscript,
even if you were to have coding agents
that were tracking their get commits at
the level of the line,
um every single commit should be within
the syntax
and semantics of the repo and project.
So, every single stateful update to the
manuscript is going to
stay within the zone of renderable PDF.
So, whether the velocity of commits was
one per month
or whether you had multiple work trees
and merging on the manuscript, you could
um always just snap render
with one command
the um most updated
uh
run.
And it's like
editing the code,
you might have a few parts where you're
between full refactors, but similarly,
keeping this idea of like a renderable,
runnable, validated,
interpretable, configurable, end-to-end
from the first start of the project,
including starting up a project, and
I've seen this multiple times by myself
and other people in this and in kind of
related areas,
bringing the old project all information
into
one of the folders.
Like um a transcript from a conversation
or rant or prior version of of the
document. And then saying,
"Drag it in.
Here is my prior work on this topic.
Reformat it refactor it into this
project format."
And then it will kind of fill in the
gaps and add the project tests and all
that
in a pretty useful way.
So, here's
like the area handbook.
That that's being live edited by one of
the agents in cursor,
but still called through anti-gravity.
It
rendered.
So, keeping keeping the um
keeping it working end-to-end
is very helpful.
And then the the output folder,
like the the very top the um
folder here
is just the copied outputs.
Just so that you can just delete this
whole folder
with one button.
And then note but also the outputs get
copied in to a project level, so that
the the all the outputs are
tracked within the project's possible
private get repo.
And then also copied the output for easy
deletion
and to kind of like if this could be
each project could be one of the
chapters of your dissertation.
And then the output would be the whole
dissertation. Chapter, you know, 0 1 2 3
4 5.
Um multi-project summary.
Just reports on the the number of
projects and such.
Let's look at the newspaper.
Okay. No, not in long versions.
Um okay.
It If there's a a comment in the next 30
seconds, I'll look at it. Otherwise, I'm
about to end this.
All right. Um I will
push these.
I'm going to
let these finish for a few seconds, push
them the current state to the GitHub,
and then probably prune these projects
away.
Um I'll remove them into an archive or
something
because they were kind of easy come,
easy go, and I want to keep the main
branch of the repo
more like
completely functional on just two to
three projects
that run pretty fast and verify the real
functionality is all working.
So,
all of that
finishing stream.
All that is at the
um docsology template
repo
updated right now.
And the projects are in the projects
folder.
That's where you can make your own
privately tracked, get ignored projects
and bootstrap bootstrap off the format.
You can or abstract and improve
as you see fit.
All right.
Thank you.
Looking forward to people's comments and
uh
where they
develop things from here.
So,
see you.
Bye.